toujours au chapitre économique et
sociale 80 salariés du site general
electric de villeurbanne ont porté
plainte contre le géant américain a lors
du rachat de la branche énergie d'alstom
en novembre 2014
general electric s'était engagé à créer
1000 emplois mais six ans après la
promesse n'a pas été tenue au contraire
le taux de création est négatif avec
3000 emplois supprimés d'où l'action en
justice action responsabilité deux des
employés se sont exprimés sur cette
action micro d'rtl france aujourd'hui on
peut en suivi des plans de
restructuration à rallonge qui se
succèdent et on en arrive à a+ licenciés
qu'embaucher et s'il est acceptable
donc aujourd'hui on veut faire valoir ce
droit à contester et pouvoir et pouvoir
connaître et montrer les préjudices
qu'ils ont subis
on se retrouve vraiment souffrance et on
s'inquiète encore de l'avenir même si se
paie cela n'est pas terminé on
s'inquiète déjà de l'avenir et de des
prochaines choses qui vont arriver
il est confiant et images à choses en
disant que c'est des engagements qui
sont qui n'ont pas été tenues comme nous
nous soyons si aujourd'hui on devait
tenir des engagements on les tient pas
on serait sanctionné la place est pareil
c'est pas parce que jean électrique à
payer 50 millions à l'état qu'ils ont le
droit de détruire 100 personnes et les
familles qui sont qui sont avec donc
aujourd'hui on est 80 se manifester on
espère qu'on sera plus parce qu'on est
beaucoup beaucoup plus impactés il ya un
gros des engagements on est ans est ce
aujourd'hui sur l'aspect social de la
restructuration
80 des % des salariés de grid ne croient
plus aux enjeux de l'entreprise quoi
c'est à dire ils ne sont plus dans le
dans le discours de la direction quoi il
ya un désengagement est une des missions
entre guillemets des des salariés de
l'entreprise et du management il ya
derrière cette cette procédure il ya
aussi une demande forte au niveau des
organisations syndicales que le
gouvernement fasse appliquer un certain
nombre de deux
deux choses de promesses qui tient c'est
à dire de garder des activités
essentielles en france et aujourd'hui
nos activités de transport d'électricité
font partie des activités essentielles
et general electric est en train de s'en
séparer en france progressivement quoi